peu plus
[Musique]
l'inconstance c'est pas facile de vous
trouver un parce que de l'extérieur on
dirait pas c'est une épicerie si je sais
bien mais puissent aller lui indiquer
une salle mais dit voir vous avez quel
âge moins de constance je vais prendre
quatre mamies syndicales ou et à 88 ans
vous continuez à travailler c'est ma
santé
si ma santé je pourrais pas être assise
dans une chaise à regarder la télévision
ou khatami jeu serait paralysée à 21
jours pour moi c'est une distraction
c'est une distraction goût du monde que
si j'étais seul je ne dirais pas ça me
donne de corbion voir des camarades dont
on parle encore du mieux ta et vous êtes
toute la journée derrière votre comptoir
robin vous savez quand même qu'en
juillet doit on s'en va cueillir et
poursuivre quand même au jardin parce
que nous faut du mouvement
ah oui oui de votre jardin et les droits
et le côté petit café oui et alors vous
savez qu'il ya une comédie pour y aller
parce qu'il faut que je lève la jambe
comme ça par dessus la rambarde faire
pour pouvoir aller la mode a maintenant
l'accès rentrer dare d'alors et non est
bouclée donc votre âge alors vous faites
la machine la gymnastique deux ou trois
fois par jour alors j'estime à rethel
lassissi d'être
est aux premiers âges de chalets ou
alors 55 et 75 sp francs 10 mai alors
que ninon va vous êtes la fille de
madame constance madame merci à vous
donner un coup de main morte rapporte à
directoire et elle voulait se ranger
quelques fois la boutique un peu d'ordre
non j'ai une habitude comprenez vous
aider à faire ça soit 120 personnes dans
les mêmes boîtes alors magie vol et je
vois mieux faire n'est pas ma
marchandise saveurs jeu le commerce et
si je travaille surtout avec le passage
surtout à double bossage quand tu alité
des gens qui arrêtent sur la place de
l'église vous avez des anglais vous avez
des âmes en vous avez d'étrangers mon
cou qui pose avec escale à sanaa
les bananes oui
tous deux noyés au citron c'est pas si
au citron vert
mais quand même merci merci merci vous
côtoyer toutes les nations comme cela
peu près une convention je voyais est
devenue l'année dernière humide et
hollandais death le demander les
allemands c'est à cause de la loire
quatre étrangers si la wii c'est à cause
de la loire la beauté de l'alma parce
que si tu as une partie de la loi quelle
est la plus belle ici un jour il y avait
des clients qui me disait comme ça ben
on a été ensuite on a été au lac de
constance au pied chez bosser ceux ci
sont mieux d'écouter mon bras gauche il
devait des comme ça je pourrais besoin
de l'ancic pour le web parce que de ma
fenêtre je jouais mon lac mais je
m'appelle constance aborde les films où
l'accès du lac de constance
[Musique]